[Music]  [Music]  we have a four point line out there on  the top of the key so I he likes to get  up and down to some trees  [Music]  [Applause]  to the games during have developed  chases them outside  never got his hands up  [Music]  get the test on despite  [Music]  close and these blows right back tre  yard with a rainbow  his hair  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  in pieces  you should watch out that Santa Monica  Pier moving him scoop to the hoop is  good such a difficult shot for the  handle  [Music]  he's a little bit in the NBA nice  between-the-legs fine which law  defending weights trailing is too  Houdini heat the trap right here but  just three guys he goes between three  and meet some force guys in Conyers  there it is go on go on  [Music]  [Music]  handoff five seconds for it's all over  there's a showing that I thought coming  into camp nice spin  [Music]